foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator offices in London so I thought
freedom of speech was a problem in the
music industry when last year I was
forced to apologize and take a leave of
absence from my bad Mumford and Sons
before deciding to quit because I read a
book about far left extremism in the
United States well it turns out there's
something more perilous than reading a
book that's writing a book and this
month on the 12th of August sir Salman
Rushdie was attacked in Upstate New York
in shutokwa by a man acting on a fatwa
issued in 1989 by the Ayatollah Khomeini
satanic versus which salmon Rushdie
published in 1988 turned salmon into the
lightning rod of the fault line between
what Samuel Huntington used to call The
Clash of civilizations I've been hit
from all sorts of directions the last
two years in the middle of a storm in
which rather oddly it seems as if the
victim has been made responsible for the
crime so today to speak with me is
Canadian Human Rights activist Yasmin
Mohammed who in 2019 published her in my
opinion very brave book unveiled how
Western liberals Empower radical Islam
Yasmin thank you so much for joining me
today thank you so much for having me
here today it's my pleasure and honor
and it's great to see you again we met
in 2019 just as you were I think just
published your book
um but let's I'd love to get into that
um but let's talk first about uh Simon
Rusty and the Satanic Verses what is so
offensive about the Satanic Verses
it it doesn't take much to offend
extremist Muslims the most benign
criticism is going to have them up in
arms
um I thought Salman rushdie's book was
actually quite benign he could have dug
a lot deeper he could have said a lot
more he's a poet he's a he's a right he
loves words he loves
um the Artistry of writing and
literature and I think it was a
beautifully written book and it captures
for what was for him a personal
experience
um you know he he didn't even really go
beyond that he just talked about
you know you could see so many parallels
with his own life and with his writing
of this book because uh you know growing
up Muslim
you
you are afraid to have certain thoughts
and you are afraid to say certain things
because of the reactions that are going
to happen but then once you do do those
things once you do say those things once
you do sort of don't follow the rules
exactly as they are prescribed to you as
we all must obey
and you sort of secretly take a step out
of line and you realize
nothing's happened
there is no higher power
that is there that is pushing me back
and punishing me for eating a ham
sandwich or whatever the you know the
edict was
um and so for him to
to question
um if these verses came from a God to
question you know the person who was
claiming that these verses came from a
God I think is a very basic question
that a lot of us
have grappled with and a lot of us have
realized that
indeed no
but you know you say that benign but
your implication then what you've just
said is that when as Rusty was exploring
these topics that were taboo topics
within Islam he must have known then it
was not a benign act to discuss them
further and really go into the specific
most controversial aspects of Muhammad's
life now the the Satanic Verses
themselves the actual Satanic Verses
that they refer to can you tell us about
what what that specific part of Islam is
what's the story behind Maha I'll get
this wrong but Muhammad was supposed to
have been told some sort of verses that
weren't actually the word of Allah and
this implies his fallibility because he
thought it was and and wrote it what's
this what's the story so the story is
that he is an an illiterate goat herder
and he is in a cave and he's fasting
um and staying solitarily in a cave this
is the Islamic story not the story from
the Satanic Verses this is the story
that we're told growing up Muslim yes
um and
he's in this cave and he starts to
hallucinate of course they don't tell us
he's hallucinating they say that he
starts to have a vision
um that an angel comes to him
and the angel tells him
read and he says I cannot read I'm
illiterate and then he says read read in
the you know in the name of your God and
blah blah blah so essentially this
this Angel is acting as the
um conduit
so instead of God speaking directly to
Muhammad he's God like tells Gabriel
things and then says hey go tell
Muhammad and so then he comes down and
he tells Muhammad you know Allah says
XYZ and so then Muhammad at that point
because he's illiterate he has to
telescribe and then the Scribe has to
write it down so it's the age-old game
of telephone you know and what happens
when you've got that many different you
know from Allah to Gabriel to Muhammad
to the Scribe you know it's natural to
think is this truly the word of God
you know it's been through a lot of
hands and things could have been
misinterpreted or added or dropped out
or changed in in that you know
chain of events
um Muhammad is supposed to be infallible
because he is the prophet so
that is cannot be the case if he if it
is yes but any thinking human being even
a Muslim you have those questions you
you do really you do think okay well
the Quran first of all wasn't even
compiled until years after Muhammad's
death
and so
this is part of the what's happening now
with reform Muslims these are the
questions that they're bringing up is
you know how how sure can we be that
this book
is truly the word of God
um and they're using that to allow them
to
interpret some of the things that are
written in there you know to allow it to
be a little bit more malleable than than
in the past well the problem I I've
always put to reformisms when I've met
them is that through the Quran it says
over and over again you must take this
word literally yeah for its work so
that's a real hurdle there for reform
Muslims to get over is it a hurdle that
can be
conquered can be can be
jumped a little bit you're you're
absolutely correct and I entirely agree
with you and I don't know what the
answer is but I don't I'm not going to
bother expending my energy trying to
overcome that hurdle
um I'm just I'd rather just walk away
from the whole thing but some people
believe that it's worth their time and
energy to try and
um overcome that hurdle and to those
people I say all the power to you you
know I completely support you because
those are people that are trying to
bring Islam into this century and so of
course I'm gonna support them in that
versus the people that are loving to
keep Islam back the way it was when the
way their Prophet practiced it which is
of course
unacceptable so uh having been raised a
Muslim I I was hoping you might
enlighten me as to Islamic blasphemy
laws and it seems to me that that is the
the problem at the root here and and
I mean I think it seems obviously the
answer to this question is yes but does
Islam have a free speech issue
they absolutely do there's no there's no
concept of free speech it's not
um
So when you say blasphemy laws that's
one thing when you talk about Sharia or
Islamic law or even like the laws of the
country so yes there there are laws of
countries that will punish people throw
them in prison even execute them for
speaking ill of the Prophet or speaking
any kind of criticism about the religion
that's one problem but then there's also
just your average Muslim citizen
like what happened with Salman richty
and in this fatwa so the state of Iran
wants to execute him but what do they do
they send out a fatal that says any
believing Muslim willing to do this will
be you know heralded and celebrated and
and it will be you know
whatever like that this will be like the
greatest act you can do with your life
so and this is powerful because at the
time of the initial factor I think the
Japanese trying because it wasn't just
for salmon rushti that the fact went out
it was anyone associated with the
publishing of the book so the Japanese
translator was uh I think murdered there
was a fire in Turkey which killed
several people attempting to kill the
Turkish translator I might be getting
some of these details uh but many people
were killed and
um
so what are the what are the the Islamic
blasphemy laws what what where where is
that rooted in the Quran
uh so yes you're not allowed to
criticize The Profit you're not allowed
to criticize the religion and if you do
you are to be executed
um and so
um that like I said that can be State
sanctioned execution or that can just be
vigilante justice by people
who are encouraged to do this because as
true believers you have to defend the
religion from criticism
and then the third type of person who
does that is the one who uses the term
islamophobia to quiet criticism so it's
really all on a spectrum we're gonna
State sanctioned execution vigilante
justice which I could give you so many
examples of that kind of thing happening
um just very briefly of Jeet Roy who is
a writer in
in Bangladesh
he was at a book fair with his wife and
he was hacked to death with machetes in
just in the streets his daughter her
sorry his wife is still missing fingers
from the machetes when she was trying to
protect her husband
um that was like
2016 I think and that's another novelist
yes yeah and
um you know and a young student in
Pakistan
um
um he was
what did he he did it was the most
benign thing again he talked about like
it was about Adam and Eve and so are we
all children of incest or something like
that and the fact that he would ask this
question in his university classroom
meant that when he got back to his dorm
that day there was a crowd of people
waiting for him and they beat him to
death
when his mother went to identify his
body she said
even kissing his hand even his pinky
finger bones were broken like every
single bone in his body was broken
because he dared to ask questions about
this religion that should never be
criticized
um so yeah it's an absolute zero
tolerance you so you saw this with
Charlie ABDO you saw this with Fleming
Rose the cartoonist from Denmark you you
know you see this over and over and over
and over again we see we've still
actually in Britain earlier this year
there's a Shia made film called the the
lady of Heaven about Fatima the daughter
of Muhammad and uh cineworld I believe
and other Cinemas decided to count out
to protesters uh in not just London but
I think Bradford and a couple other
sports
um and removed the film from being shown
and
um what was peculiar about that was that
it was it seemed to be within Islam
between Shia and Sunni so at first
glance I thought oh well the Shia here
are taking the more free speech root and
the Sunni sects were were against them
but actually turned out to be more
complicated because the Iranian
government had also forbidden the film
and and so there seems to be a war
within Islam on on free speech going on
yes well that's the problem is like will
The Real Islam please stand up right
they can't they can't decide amongst
themselves what is the
you know everything is blasphemy because
it according to somebody's opinion it's
going to be blasphemous
so it is so dangerous to speak about the
religion to any kind of literature art
movies anything
um because you never know who you're
going to offend
and what was interesting about that
movie that you mentioned there is that
even Muslims can't criticize their own
religion they can't even question their
own religion or they can't even offer a
perspective
um if other Muslims disagree with them
they will also silence them and this
happens all the time there's Ahmadi
Muslims to the to the point that in the
Pakistani to get a Pakistani passport
you have to sign that you don't believe
that Ahmadi Muslims are actual Muslims
like look why why why why do you need
that in order it's just another flavor
of Muslim but the sunnis want to sort of
have a monopoly on what they believe to
be true Islam and so they don't want any
other sects or reformers or any other
variations and so that's the kind of
Islam that I grew up in which is the
um you know the what now people are
calling salafi or wahhabi so it's Back
to Basics back to the way the prophet
lived
um fundamentalist fundamentalists the
most pure example would be Isis they
followed the steps of what their Prophet
did the leader of Isis had its PhD in
Islamic Studies and he was you know
um very very precise
in making sure that they followed the
rules of their religion the way he saw
it the difficult
thing that jumped to say that jumps up
what I'm saying is is that actually uh
or rather I'm finding it hard to just
discern radical Islam from Islam Islam
in what you're implying here and and
there's a common when the argument when
it comes the argument is it's often said
oh you know most liberal Muslims or or
most Muslims don't represent these these
this way of thought this way of thinking
but uh the sort of implication
I think here is that actually true
Muslims do have this but not for me to
say but do you think that's yeah I think
the best way to sort of
um
uh illustrate this is with a parallel
with the Old Testament so there is no
New Testament in Islam so when you look
at the Old Testament and the way that it
asks Christians to live and act and be
it's pretty harsh
um and you're you're gonna have a
difficult time finding Christian people
that actually follow the Old Testament
by the letter and you're also not going
to be able to find any countries that
have laws from the Old Testament in
their countries
um well except that Israel is the Old
Testament is the Hebrew Bible right so
yes but yeah they like to think of
themselves as a democracy but yes so
this is I also disagree I disagree with
I'm I'm I believe in secularism I com I
think that there should be a complete
separation of church and state entirely
but what I'm trying to express is that
um even though
there is scriptural evidence for
um acting a certain way or for being a
certain way in the Old Testament most
Christians do not follow it and do not
live that way that is a truth because
they're following the New Testament
um but what happens with Islam is the
Quran is the
like the Old Testament and that is the
that is the book that Muslims follow
so we kind of have to make a
differentiation between Islam the
religion and Muslims the people because
the religion demands this
the religion says for example that you
know if you
if you steal to cut off your right hand
and your left foot or whatever the
barbaric rules are but that doesn't mean
that most Muslims are actually following
those specific rules
um
so what you're saying is is true however
most Muslims do know that that's what
the religion demands and that when there
is an Islamic State and that we should
be they should be trying and hoping for
an Islamic State that will follow the
rules of a snap so even though they
don't actively engage in those things
they know that that's the correct thing
that should be done and if they're not
doing it they should be striving towards
doing it as soon as they can
I'd I would have to take a little bit
I'd like to challenge you on some of the
what you said about the the Christian
Bible there but that's perhaps for
another
um well you know what you're probably
100 correct because I shouldn't even
I've grew up Muslim and I'm very
familiar with that religion yeah and I'm
trying my best to try and create
Parallels for people so that they can
understand this context but in the same
way that I'm fully you know versed in
Islam I'm other people are fully versed
in their own religions and they're not
fully verse in Islam and so
um I guess we're both like kind of
trying to reach out to each other and
and create those parallels as much as we
can so that we can understand each other
but it's hard to do when this is the
um this is your experience and this is
your understanding and yours is
completely different and so we have to
try and find a you know like I'm not I'm
not familiar with Christianity I'm not
familiar with the Bible I'm not familiar
with uh you know other than just what I
would know the stream uh uh
for another time but uh uh you have uh
you published a book as I said earlier
in 2019
um uh unveiled about and it's a uh half
of it and my memory is correct it's
autobiographical about how you escaped I
hope you don't mind me using that
language no not at all a forced marriage
to a high-ranking member of al-Qaeda
um
for people who haven't read the book or
who might be interested in reading the
book what what can you tell us about
um about that that story I appreciated
it's very personal so
um perhaps listeners should just go and
buy the book but but um what can you
tell us
um so like I mentioned I grew up in a in
a very I guess what would these days be
considered fundamentalist or extremist
households you know at the time I just
thought I was a regular Muslim these
were all the Muslims around me were the
same
um I was put in Canada in Canada yes uh
so I was put in hijab at uh nine years
old
because that's the age
um and
I went to Islamic schools and you know
education was never valued I knew that
my whole purpose in this world was to
marry young and make make more babies
make more Muslims to grow the ummah to
grow the community of Muslims
um and uh you know to be a good wife and
to learn how to obey and and all that
stuff
but I was never really good at
being subservient and conforming I was
always
questioning and pushing and so that was
something that um
my mother and her husband tried to beat
out of me
um and they almost succeeded a few times
and eventually what ended up happening
was I was left in Egypt
um
my family all went back to Canada and
they left me in Egypt and my mom figured
if I was in an Muslim majority country
in an Islamic environment that there was
very little trouble that I could get
into because her
when I talk about me being problematic I
mean that I was
um attracted to things like Freedom
liberalism feminism right like these
were Concepts that I was interested in
and
um I wanted to have non-muslim friends I
didn't think that they were all these
evil people that were out to get me and
wanted me dead
um and so she figured if she left me
there that I would
straighten out or something and they
tried to
forced me into a marriage with my cousin
um
and I was able to get out of Egypt but I
was I was broken very exhausted
um at that point I was 18.
and I had been fighting with my mother
my whole life because when I was about
12 years old I also went to one of my
teachers and then he went to Social
Services and got the police involved and
um you know I took my mom and her
husband to court for the way that they
were abusing me and
that turned out very badly in my favor
when the judge said that um
you know this is your culture this is
your family this is how they choose to
to discipline you so
he just left me
um
and so there was always this friction so
the Canadian government there really let
you down absolutely is that something do
you think that's changed in Canada since
then I wish I could say it has but I
just recently read
um
other than the people that contact me
and tell me their heart-wrenching
stories
um
you know there was just a case about a
Syrian girl whose nose was broken by her
father she's 14 years old because he
found out that she had
um texted with a boy
and same thing they refused to
take her out of that home and to protect
her
um still in Canada still in Canada yeah
in a different Province even so it
doesn't even matter like it's these are
provincial
courts but that's just the way Canada is
like it's it's very
it's it's
um
it's kind of like possessed with this
diversity and inclusion and
multiculturalism kind of ideas which are
just
riddled with cultural relativism and
moral relativism and they really cannot
see
that
Muslim girls are human beings similar to
other Canadian girls in the country I
mean they are Canadian girls they
shouldn't be treated any differently but
they really do feel that the
um the religion of Islam or the culture
of Muslims needs to be protected above
the actual
human being
and they prove that over and over and
over again this is what the Italian
author and journalist orianna falachi
one of her opinions was that liberalism
would eventually
kill itself because it would tolerate
ideologies that would not intolerate
liberalism and and we've seen that in in
a version of that in Britain with the
with the grooming gangs and if you I saw
there's one report that that South
Yorkshire police had not reported the
ethnicity as 67 of the cases
um and thousands of cases and uh or
thousands of girls rather and um because
they were worried about it coming across
as racist because the majority
um are of Pakistan of the of the
grooming gangster of Pakistani Pakistani
Pakistani origin origin and and so that
that's a problem we have here as well
but take us to back to Egypt then so
you're 18 you're in Egypt your mother's
sent you there too yeah well I was 17
when I was sent there when I was 18
um when I was able to get out between 18
and 19 and
um
so like I say you know my relationship
with my mom had deteriorated so much
because
for so many years she had just been
trying to get me to submit which is the
definition of the word Islam
um
and although sometimes I would submit
for short periods of time I would get
back up again and she was getting really
frustrated with me and so she
as she told me I she chose a man for me
who was strong enough to control me
and so that's why she chose
um
a terrorist and
it it's important to note here that
um
yes he's a terrorist but from my mom's
perspective is he was also
an incredibly good Muslim so he's just a
good man she thought he was like
following the example of the Prophet
better than any man she'd ever met
and so
she thought he would be strong enough
both physically be the fact that he's a
terrorist
um and also
um
with like how Pious he was and how good
of a person he was so that would keep me
controlled finally
um
and
it worked he had me completely covered
in Black from head to toe
um couldn't even have my eyes out that's
if I left the house anyway
um
he had papered the windows in the house
just in case the curtain would move and
somebody would see me
so he covered all of the windows and
paper
I got
pregnant pretty soon after because in
Islam a woman is not allowed to say no
to her husband
um
and
so I was really only leaving the house
once a month to go to my prenatal visits
to the doctor other than that I never
left the house
and once I had my daughter that's when
that's when everything for me changed
because I felt like
um so much intense love for her and
really wanted to support her and to have
her be happy and to never know sadness
and
um protect her
and
um
I never wanted her to live the life that
I had lived you know the life that I was
always trying to push myself out of now
I have this beautiful little girl and
I'm going to condemn her to that life if
if I don't get us out
and um
you know you have these thoughts but at
the same time you are a completely
demoralized completely dehumanized young
girl with a high school education and no
support system whatsoever
and so even though I had these thoughts
I didn't have the
courage to do anything about getting
myself out
and
you know one of the moments
that I remember feeling like I have to
do no matter what it is I have to get my
daughter out of this environment was
when she was just a baby and he leaned
in and asked me when I was like when was
I gonna clean her
and I said what do you mean clean her
she just had a bath he's like no when
are you gonna get her fixed
and I was I don't I don't understand
what you mean and then my mom says oh no
no when she's five or six years old
we'll take her to Egypt and we'll get
that done
and that's when I realized what they
were talking about
and
as any parent will know when you're you
know you have your
baby in your arms and you would do
absolutely anything to protect this baby
from harm and these two people are in
the room talking about taking career to
Egypt to get her cut with razor blades
you know
so
um that was the moment I knew I had to
um
I had to get her out I had to get myself
out
and
it's all in the book but obviously it
wasn't a
it wasn't an easy thing to do and
honestly I'm very grateful that I was
able to get out in my
interview with ion hercielli who I know
you've been on her podcast as well like
she talks about how the fact that we are
alive today the fact that we were got
free and were you know speaking about
this publicly is truly a miracle it's an
absolute Miracle
um
you know if not for the flap of a
butterfly's wing at some point this you
know I would have been
in Peshawar with 10 children with a
terrorist husband you know but luckily
my daughter and I got out and he is in
prison in Egypt
thank you so much for sharing that um
uh well I have read the book and as I
said earlier I think you're
astonishingly Brave uh woman
um the the subtitle of the book is how
Western liberals Empower radical
Islam and I think you were hinting at
this earlier in the conversation as to
the the third problem of free speech in
Islam is that is is the use of
aslamophobia to shut down if I'm not
because it isn't quite we didn't quite
get there and misrepresent what you were
about to say about how islamophobia as a
term is used to shut down speech on the
difficult issues within Islam so how do
Western liberals Empower radical Islam
well I think even if we go back to your
example of that Lady of Fatima movie
that's another perfect example I give so
many examples of my book and
unfortunately new examples are being
you know brought to light every single
day but
um
for the
the film you know the the cinemas to
capitulate to the mobs of people that
were demanding that they stopped showing
this film
when they capitulate to these this mob
of bullies it empowers them to continue
every single time they win
they have such a huge morale boost
and they will truly say things like you
see you see how we the even the big
powerful West the big powerful Great
Britain you see how we can bring them to
their knees because we have a law behind
us that's why so these are this is the
kind of rhetoric you would have heard
after 9 11. this is the kind of this is
after Salman Rushdie was stabbed you
know this is the the worst possible
thing we can do
is
Empower them by capitulating
to their demands
so one of the best responses to this was
in France so you'll remember the teacher
Samuel petite who was beheaded
as he was walking home to his wife and
child after school one day
um
beheaded because he showed a picture
of Muhammad but a cartoon of Muhammad in
his class because he was discussing free
speech
with his students
um
after that happened there were quite a
few cities around France that took those
cartoons and they projected them on
buildings
and I thought that was the most perfect
response
if they try to silence you this is
actually a Salman rishti has a quote
where he says if they try to silence you
sing louder
um and that's what we should have done
that's what we should do oh are you
upset about this movie being shown in
this Cinema okay well watch this we're
going to show it in even more Cinemas
you're gonna have to go around and
protest in front of every single one of
them you you cannot
you cannot
capitulate to bullies they all they will
do is just demand more and more and more
and more and more until everything is as
they want it to be what they want is the
exact opposite of what we want so I like
I mentioned before there's no such thing
as freedom of expression in Islam like
the there's no such thing as as freedom
of speech so that's what they're hoping
that's their end goal
and so every time we capitulate and we
allow them
to get their way with silencing us
whether it's with the word islamophobia
or whether it's getting movies
taken down or whether it's people
unwilling to to share the you know
cartoons of of Charlie ABDO or of
Fleming Rose or any even just to even
use our voices to criticize
um The Grooming gangs for goodness sake
um journalists and politicians were all
losing their jobs over that
um every single time we do that we are
empowering them more and more and more
well British listeners will be familiar
with the Batley grammar yes a teacher
case and he's been well over a year now
and like the French
um teacher he showed a picture I believe
it was the same hepto cartoon but I
might be getting that wrong and he has
been forced to go into hiding and he
remains in hiding and terrified for his
life and there's not been uh much of a
responsive solidarity at all
um so uh
in a way it's it's a you know great
shame but you're you're right about this
for let's say someone's listening
doesn't really understand the
islamophobia uh example one way I I
describe it is it's Islam is a set of
ideas but Muslim Muslims are people so I
would have a problem with people people
who are Muslim phobic
but not but to criticize Islam isn't a
problem what what what if to someone who
doesn't understand the problem of the
word islamophobia how would you
articulate it well it's exactly what you
just said there like it's a set of ideas
it's like you know
um it's like it's like communism it's
like Nazism it's like any other
set of ideas a way of that peop somebody
thinks that we should all be living so
how you know
the fact that they're trying to stop
people from criticizing a set of ideas I
mean that's the most egregious
um you know it's against Free Speech
it's against free expression so the
point is that we should be able and in
fact we should criticize
sets of ideas
and the fact that people are trying to
silence us from doing that
like there there seems to be this um
role reversal going on where you know
for me as a person who has denounced
Islam
the religion says that I should be
executed I'm not allowed to criticize
that I'm not allowed to say anything
about that the religion says that women
are less intelligent than men the
religion says that men should beat their
wives if they fear that they might be
disobedient or arrogant I could go on
and on and on about all of the horrible
things that are in that religion and
I should be able to criticize those
things and I will criticize those things
and the people that are trying to
silence me from criticizing those things
are the same people are with the same
thought processes as the people that are
you know attacking Salman Rushdie or or
killing the the Charlie hebdo cartoonist
but instead of using
um
instead of using bullets and or knives
they're using these this term
islamophobia it's just another way of
scaring me into silence where I'm going
to be so afraid that somebody's going to
call me a bigot or someone's going to
call me racist or somebody's gonna call
me an islamophobe that I'll just go
silent and people do that all the time
it does work it's a it's it's a
successful mechanism for silencing
criticism
um and you know the
there's no mechanic like what what what
what's very frustrating for me is that
when people want to criticize I'm going
to talk about Christianity again so you
may you may have you know some other
criticisms of me but you know you can
criticize Judaism you can criticize
Christianity you can criticize Hinduism
and then what do the people from those
groups do they engage in conversation
they engage in discourse and they say
actually I think you misunderstood this
is the situation or whatever it is like
they they engage with you
they don't try to behead you
or burn down the building of of where
this criticism has come from or whatever
the situation may be you know so it's
like Muslims are so unwilling to come to
the table and have rational discourse
like rational human beings you either
have the extremists that are coming out
with their with their guns and knives or
you have the islamists that are coming
forward with their islamophobia you know
basically again silencing the criticism
and very very few reform Muslims that
we've mentioned before are willing to
sit down and have these conversations
but again to go back to the subtitle of
my book how Western liberals Empower
radical Islam we're not hearing from
those reform Muslims those aren't the
people that were were you know we're not
having them
on you know the BBC or CNN or or
whatever we're not talking to them we're
not listening to what they have to say
politicians don't care what they have to
say because they are a minority
within a minority and they're more
interested in the votes of who what do
what do the the
what do most Muslims believe or think or
you know
um and that I think is
is the real tragedy here I think that we
need to be
encouraging and empowering reform
Muslims who within their own religion
are trying to make changes
you know like I said to you earlier I
don't necessarily agree with what
they're doing and how they're doing it
but I do certainly support them
um and
you know I think that's what we need to
be doing we need to be supporting the
progressive minded you know the
feminists and the Muslim majority world
I think that we need to be supporting
people like the Batley grammar school
teacher for example there should have
been like this huge solidarity that
would show
no we are not going to be bullied no we
are not going to capitulate to you
that's what we need to do and you've got
people all over the Muslim majority
world that are trying to do this but
like I said they're a tiny minority and
they're within a society of people that
want them dead
and so it's very difficult to hear their
voices so I feel like people that
believe in Western values people that
believe in Enlightenment values people
that believe in important Concepts like
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression
we should be linking hands with each
other across the globe and supporting
each other
but unfortunately that's not what's
what's happening instead we're linking
hands with terrorists in Afghanistan or
you know murderers in Saudi Arabia and
it's all you know just for political
reasons
I understand in the publishing of your
book unveiled you faced great difficulty
um can you tell us a little bit about
that yeah so
um
I had a great agent here in the UK and
she sent my book out to many different
Publishers and they all came back with
the same response and that you know
always had something to do with Salman
Rushdie they said we don't have the
capacity
um to take on such a security threat and
so we're not interested in publishing
this book we think it's a great book
it's well written we agree with you know
a lot of things that she's saying Etc et
cetera
um but we're not going to touch it with
a 10-foot pole because they were scared
of the consequences they were scared
that they would face the wrath of those
extremists yes they weren't willing to
um
that's Yeah so basically like what I was
saying early they they weren't willing
to stand up for their own values they're
not willing to to stand up against the
bullies they're not willing to
so one can only imagine Free Speech what
books are not getting published there's
a British academic called a very
brilliant academic called Emma Webb who
described this recently uh in in an
interview on Andrew doors show as
internalization of Islamic blasphemy
laws
yeah in effect now westerners and this
comes to the title of your book how uh
how Western Liberals are empowering
radical Islam is that
because people are scared a rusty type
response and let's look at the
publishing they are now not publishing
books and so we are not and and it's
winning and and uh that's a quite a
terrifying thought and I I I I I wonder
how many books uh we're not having the
opportunity to read but and yeah you did
publish you self-published I did I
self-published because I got frustrated
I got tired of that response
um and uh you know I was speaking to Sam
Harris who is somebody who I greatly
admire and respect and I told him I'm
done I'm sick of this whole thing you
know
the West can just burn itself you know
I'm over it I've tried to say what I
needed to say nobody wants to hear me
all they want to do is silence me and
demonize me because it was not only
coming from the Muslims it's coming very
strongly from the left as well
um and so I felt like you know
I'm I'm over it I'm not doing this
anymore
and he sat on the phone with me for
almost an hour basically talking me off
the ledge and saying you know you need
to publish this book you you need to
just self-publish this book you need to
get it out there
um and I didn't
believe him I didn't want to do it but I
trusted him enough
that I thought well I'll just I'll just
do it and
um it was essentially him and my and my
husband who made it happen because I was
so demoralized at that point
um and together they you know created
the cover art and they just they did
everything
and got it published
and I was really really really pleased
to see the responses
um because it was like you said there's
so many people out there
that are thinking and feeling these same
things but they can't say it and the
fact that I had written down what they
felt were their internal thoughts
um they felt so less alone and so
um
you know validated
and so I was getting
messages from all over the world from
people telling me how much they relate
to my story and and telling me their
stories and saying that reading my story
felt like reading their story and
um
you know it's obviously been that that
part of it has been really wonderful to
to connect with so many people across
the globe
but but yeah you know it's still I'm
still getting messages every now and
then from random people who haven't even
read my book telling me what an
islamophobe I am you know full-on
American Born and Raised have nothing to
do with Islam have never known anything
to do with Islam but they feel that they
have the the right
to to judge me and to demonize me you
know the the they don't have the right
to do that they do but just the
arrogance of it you know just the
arrogance of of
being so ignorant about something
and then feeling that you need to
silence people who are trying to share
their expression Express their opinions
about it
um yeah it's just
uh and but you are
um turning you're sort of ignoring the
hate and uh riding the way of positivity
and doing a lot of good and I've seen
and perhaps you can tell me about uh
free Hearts free Minds your non-profit
organization yeah well that's actually a
perfect segue because once my book I've
I started publishing
um chapter by chapter on a Blog online
and when I was started to do that I
started to get inundated with messages
from people all around the world
um
who couldn't speak to their friends and
family about what they were thinking and
feeling but they knew that they could
share with me because I had already
publicly expressed how I you know my
opinions
and
so they were all writing to me and
telling me their stories and sharing
their situations with me I mean I had
women from Saudi Arabia calling me from
inside of like prisons it's like this
place where women who don't submit our
throne
I had this woman from Somalia calling me
where her family members had found out
that she didn't believe in Islam anymore
and they had alerted Boko Haram which
are a terrorist group and she had three
days to to recant and to say that she
was a Muslim again before they were
going to execute her
um
just the most atrocious things and
people are reaching out to me and I'm
like I'm just a woman writing a blog
like I don't have the power I don't have
a magic wand of course I I would do
anything than I can to support anybody
that I can but I did not have the
capacity to do so
um and it broke me I ended up just
um
I ended up falling in the darkest place
I'd ever fallen in in my life and I was
I was suicidal I was agoraphobic I was
having
panic attacks it was it was so difficult
and
that's when I came to
the thought of developing this
organization free Hearts free Minds
which offers
the support that these people need but
it's through professionals not me
because I was not capable of doing it I
was already raw anyway because I was in
the middle of writing my book
um which brought up all sorts of things
that I had buried for decades and that I
never wanted to look at and suddenly I
was trying to examine them to write it
into this book
um so I was already in a really fragile
state so what I do with free Hearts free
Minds is basically people know that they
can trust me and so they contact me
looking for support and then I can at
that point
refer them to therapists who can support
them to overcome their religious trauma
and so we have three therapists that
work with us Aisha Jessica and Joanna
and I could not be more grateful and
more proud of the work that we do we
have the most
amazing team of people and we have a
really really
you know just
it's like the light in a dark tunnel
it's eight sessions of of group support
where they not only have an opportunity
to work through their religious trauma
but they have an opportunity to find
Community again which is what you lose
when you're ostracized and
excommunicated and fearing for your life
so um yeah so I'm incredibly proud of my
organization free Hearts free minds and
it allows me to feel like I'm doing
something positive in the tsunami of
negatives that are constant
Consulting certainly are that's
absolutely wonderful and very inspiring
to hear yasmi Muhammad thank you so much
for sharing your story and speaking with
me today it's been fascinating thank you
so much with my pleasure
thank
you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]